so what I want to do here is run over
the secret origin of Tony Stark and the
reason why is because what bindus is
doing with invincible Iron Man from
all-new all-different marvel is basing
Tony Stark on this particular origin
story and moving forward with a series
that stands alone from the previously
existing Ironman titles and so what
we're gonna do is jump into why this
story was made transition to the origin
story itself and then wrap around to the
events that led to the revelation in the
first place and so while this might seem
a little weird bear with me here
and I think it'll all make sense at the
end
so the secret origin of Tony Stark comes
out of Iron Man vol 5 issues number 10
through 17 as part of the Marvel now
line of comics written by Kieron Gillen
during a 2013 interview with Comic Book
Resources he had stated that the idea of
rewriting Tony Stark's origin story was
twofold
the first was that the Iron Man comic
was celebrating its 50th year and as a
result Marvel was looking for a way to
retell his story in a way that would
appeal to newer audiences and the second
was to introduce a more compelling
dynamic in the form of Tony Stark's
brother Arno and redefined Tony's
relationship with his parents in
addition to this because the event of
Avengers vs. x-men was taking place at
this time Marvel wanted a way to
introduce these concepts without
contradicting the Avengers vs. x-men
conflict and to this end Kieron Gillen
initiated the events of secret origins
by having Tony Stark take to outer space
in an effort to explore its furthest
regions as a way to prepare himself for
the various threats that may endanger
the earth and so with issue number 7
Kieran introduced a red jelly and
recorder named for 51 as a series of
robots created by a highly advanced race
called the woge elion who operated as
colonizers of worlds during the early
age of the universe the recorders were
created to function similarly to the
watcher in that they explore new
territories and reported back to their
masters on the nature of the explored
areas inhabitants and the level of
difficulty and colonization
however weather recorders were normally
wiped of their memories and sent back
into space to continue the process of
exploration 451 was a recorder whose
memory was not wiped and as a result
began to develop a personality of his
own defecting from the resilience he
began the process of exploring the
universe for the purpose of expanding on
his own understanding of existence
operating as a guide of sorts what
Marvel does here is provide us with the
backstory or 4:51 in terms of his
knowledge about Tony Stark and why it
took a particular interest in him during
this story
so the secret origin of Tony Stark
initially picks up with Howard Maria
Stark what we're told here is that the
two are around three months pregnant and
while Marshall doesn't explicitly come
out and say it the context of their
conversation regarding the issues
they've been through indicate that
they've tried to have a child several
times before but it failed each time and
this is something that's compounded on
when the two meet with their doctor to
follow up on the pregnancy and are
informed that the baby will likely not
make it to term and if it did the child
they would receive is not the child that
they want now whether this means that
the baby would be born with birth
defects or died during the birthing
process is never explained but for
Howard Stark the inability to produce a
child with his wife is really a central
part of his self-definition what I mean
here is that for Howard the desire to
pass on his lineage is a driving force
behind who he is as a person and how he
defines himself as a man in his eyes the
inability to have a child with his wife
despite his vast influence power and
wealth lead him to believe that on a
fundamental level he simply failed as
both a man and a husband
now what Kieron Gillen does here is
provide us with a measure of desperation
on behalf of Howard Stark and then he
takes a kind of dr. strange approach
here where the origin of dr. Stephen
strain saw him visiting various doctors
and specialists following his car
accident and the damage to his hands
Howard Stark visits some of the greatest
minds on earth in an effort to find
someone who can help his situation
the reason why is because Maria suffers
from an illness which has complicated
her pregnancy and while the baby has
lasted three months Howard is looking
for someone who could ensure that the
baby will be born after nine months in a
healthy manner as a result something
like artificial insemination would
result in the same problem that they're
currently facing and so while various
individuals like the High Evolutionary
has stated that they are essentially
unable to provide Howard with the
answers that he seeks hope does come in
the form of a shady individual named mr.
Rollo and a seedy bar in Las Vegas
revealing himself to be a member of an
alien race called the greys a group
created explicitly for this comic and
survives by scavenging for technology of
other societies Willow agrees to help
Howard
but only under the condition that Howard
helps them in return what Wallace says
is that at some point he and his group
came into contact with 451 on earth
while they try to access the information
stored within him as a way to expand on
and ensure their survival for 51 refused
to provide them with his information and
simply just shut down unable to access
it the grace kept for 51 under lock and
key until such a time as they could
download all of this information
however while walking to the ship for 51
simply woke up and in the process
offered Rollo the opportunity to turn
against his boss in exchange for data
that would be worth a fortune and taking
the opportunity Rollo was provided with
a list of names by 451 one of whom was
Howard Stark and so seeing the vast
information within 451 as a way to
possibly cure his wife and bear a child
Howard Stark agrees to help Rollo
forming a team composed of minor Marvel
characters including Dum Dum Dugan
the former right-hand man of Nick Fury
and a howling commando during World War
two as well as Thunderbolt Ross prior to
his promotion to general Ross in
addition to ness of the kitten the group
functions similar to Ocean's eleven in
that they each had an area of expertise
including demolitions espionage and
security and would work with willow 2 3
4 51 from his captivity with Rolo acting
as a decoy for his boss by pitching a
story that he was involved in a deal
that had gone south Howard Stark and his
team break into the office of rolos boss
and begin to break 4:51 out however once
Rolo his boss begins to realize what's
happening he makes the argument that if
what Rolo says is true then his
stupidity has crossed the greys a
valuable robot and if Rolo is lying that
he should be eliminated either way
Rollo's boss kills him as he saw Rolo to
be more of a liability than anything
else and so with 451 freed the story
transitions to Howard Emery astark in
their mansion during a conversation with
451 as it explains it has knowledge to
ensure that their child is born healthy
but the problem is that because this is
taking place during the time period
occurring with the rise of the x-men and
the superpower teams of the Avengers and
the Fantastic Four as well as spider-man
various alien empires have begun to
recognize the thread that earth is
beginning to become what 451 says is
that in 30 years
alien civilizations will stop
viewing earth out of curiosity and begin
viewing it out of fear and that at some
point they will destroy humanity in an
effort to keep mutants and super-powered
people from expanding into space in an
effort to keep this from happening 451
sought to modify the baby of Howard
Maria by enhancing it with an aptitude
for technological advancement that would
help humanity evolve at a much faster
rate and ensure its survival
once alien races began to pose a threat
assembling a genetic code that would
merge with the baby once it reached
maturity the child would possess
knowledge in all forms of technology
covered in the database of 451 its brain
would be at a maximum of the human
potential in terms of intelligence
practicality would take precedence over
a sense of wonder meaning that the child
would never view something as impossible
to achieve
and finally the child would derive
inspiration from viewing unfamiliar
objects and develop new technologies
from existing ones and however what the
story also reveals is that when Howard
Emma Rhea would provide it with the
option of allowing the genetic
modification of the child to occur the
two suddenly exchanged their thoughts on
whether or not 451 should be trusted
from the perspective of both Howard
Maria 451 offered the best chance for
the two to give birth to a son but using
his knowledge of Technology Howard Stark
intended to secretly analyze the genetic
modification provided by 451 and an
effort to ensure that it wasn't lying
but during his investigations Howard
Stark discovered that within the genetic
code was a suicide gene that would allow
their son to grow until he was around
the age of thirty two years old at which
point he would simply die seeking to
keep this from happening Howard Stark
developed a solution that would counter
this suicide gene allowing their son to
benefit from the genetic modification
without having his lifespan cut short
however once the child was born it began
to demonstrate an inability to breathe
on its own and when Howard ámoreá
traveled to their local doctor for a
diagnosis of the problem the doctor had
told them that while he didn't know what
the cause of the problem was the
prognosis was that the baby would never
be able to breathe on its own again
revealing to Maria that he had
discovered 451 s lie and secretly fed
her a solution to disrupt the suicide
gene Howard reason that because he
wasn't 100% familiar with the
ramifications of his actions that this
issue may have been a fallout of his act
and while Maria expressed an anger
towards Howard for both keeping her in
the dark as well as betraying her trust
in the end the two decided that the only
thing they could do was keep the child
hidden from the world and 451 since it
was unknown how it would react to
learning that Howard had modified its
work and so faced with the truth of his
history the story transitions to Tony
Stark searching through the various
documents of his father's life in an
effort to locate the truth of what he's
seen arriving at the Maria Stark
Foundation hospice for the dying Marvel
introduces Tony Stark's brother Arno for
the very first time during the
discussion
Tony reveals that he had listened to his
father's words over and over again and
while the situation was a lot to take in
at one time in the end he had come to
the realization that Arno was a
biological son born to Howard a Maria
with modified genes allowing for him to
be a genius all Tony Stark had actually
been adopted as a way to keep our know
hidden and allow the world to believe
that Howard a Maria's son grew up fine
now whether the reaction of Tony Stark
is a bit of a shock here and that he's
effectively facing a brother that he
never knew that he had for our know it's
the opposite now whether it's due to his
genetic structure in terms of being a
genius or the fact that he's meeting a
member of his family for the first time
the attitude from Arno is one of both
excitement and elation and that he's
been confined to a room hidden from the
world and now has the opportunity to
bring his ideas to the open in an effort
to make the world a better place now in
terms of this particular story and the
events that led up to it the entire
situation of twente Stark's secret
origin as Karen Gillan had wrote it came
about due to a long-term plan that 4:51
had arranged because various alien races
would view humanity as a threat the goal
of 451 was to lead Tony Stark to
something called the god killer armor
created by a race called the aspirants
at the dawn of time in an effort to
destroy the Celestials the aspirants
fell into a civil war and were destroyed
by the Celestials during their own
conflict however the god killer armor
remained and was sought by 4:51 as a way
to ensure the survival of earth by
placing it in the hands of Tony Stark
since it was the belief of 451 that
humanity was the key to bringing peace
to the universe however once it was
revealed that Tony Stark was not the
biological son of Howard Emery astark
451 sought to ensure that the guide
killer armor would not fall into the
hands of anyone who would seek to
destroy earth into this end 451 sent a
guide killer
to another dimension Antony to take
himself and Tony Stark along with it and
in the process Tony Stark hacked into
450 once technology and saved himself
from being pulled into the other
dimension and so once 451 was
effectively destroyed
this allowed Tony Stark the opportunity
to travel and meet Arno for the very
first time and for Arno to live out in
the world without fear or 451 tracking
him down one day with that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end I
hope this made sense I know this was a
little shaky but it was really just kind
of how the origin story is being given
to us in terms of the all-new
all-different version of Iron Man and
what business is pulling from before
Secret Wars that being said I will catch
you guys on him purse